now
juras adamic research scientist in the
parker institute for cancer
immunotherapy
will present us the molecular
immunologic profiling of cda t cell
responses
in patients receiving a multiple
antigen-engineered dc vaccine
good day everyone it's a pleasure to
speak at this scientific symposium
i would like to thank the organizers for
the introduction
and an invitation to present our work at
this
symposium so this work is coming from a
dendritic cell cancer vaccine clinical
trial in melanoma patients
so at the beginning of my total i'd like
to give a brief background
about melanoma and introduce the concept
of
dendritic cell cancer vaccines and then
i will introduce the clinical trial
itself
that will then transition into the data
presentation
and i have no disclosures
so melanoma is the deadliest form of
skin cancer
and it's highly metastatic now
unfortunately the rates of the diagnosis
have increased
dramatically over the past decades and
because it's highly metastatic it is of
often diagnosed in late stages
about hundred thousand americans are
expected to be diagnosed in 2020
now despite the advances in the current
treatment of melanoma and recent
developments of
immunotherapies there's still
significant portion of patients that
does not respond to these treatments
or acquire resistance during the course
of the treatment
so that for therefore this is a critical
health problem in the united states and
world
so dendritic cells are the true
connectors between the innate
and adaptive immune system uh
the idea of dendritic health uh
dendritic cell and i'm going to use dc
dc based cancer vaccines is to uh
induce new or expand a pre-existing
functional and durable tumor-specific
diesel responses
so we want the standard cells to educate
the adaptive branch specifically
cda t cells to attack and kill the tumor
cells
so there is a diagram here of a patient
example
where blood is being leukoforest and
elutriated
where the dendritic cell precursors are
being generated
and matured at some point a tumor
antigen loading process
is happening where the vaccine product
is prepared
and infused back into the patient with
hopes
of sharing this tumor antigen
presentation knowledge with the t cells
so in our case we engineered
adenovirally transduced vaccines
with three shared melanoma antigens by
rosinase smart one and may g6
so vaccines are usually safe but the
question is are they effective
there's about 200 dendritic cell
clinical trials
or more today but the efficacy of the
dendritic cell vaccines is still
questionable
in terms of our clinical trial here's a
brief summary of it a a schematic
diagram
where here at the baseline day zero
prior to that
first set of leukophoresis has been
conducted
where the vaccine product have been
generated
that is then being infused three times
into the patients
and the day 43 second set of
lycophoresis is generated
then actually patients are being divided
into two branches
with or without high-dose interference
alpha treatment
and dayday 89 then concluding over the
trial has a
another locophoresis so you can see we
have three different time points for
analysis
and there has been a wealth of molecular
and clinical data
coming out of this trial we've used
numerous things
like a cytokine cytokine serum profiling
molecular profiling of the circulating
lymphocytes
and a lot of immuno monitoring of the
lymphocytes of these patients
including tumor biopsies
so going on here just to show you a
quick quick
responses in the trial where we see some
partial responders
uh and uh of course some early
progressors unfortunately
and then we have also some no evidence
of disease patients
that were actually separated into good
and them categories
based on their time of progression so
good and bad outcomes
those are the two categories i will
refer to
so the study objective of our trial
or or or actually the study work was to
analyze
the cancer patient-specific t-cell
responses
so i'm going to go ahead and to show you
that to confirm
that the dendritic cell vaccines induced
and activated a successful
tumor-specific
responses we conducted alispot assays
from total pbmc cultures
and this demonstrated that majority of
patients showed actually increased in
interferon gamma producing t
cells in response to the antigens and
that indicated successful vaccination
now the closer look at the baseline
responses shown at the bottom there
show that about half of the patient
showed pre-existing
functional pistol responses to the
melanoma antigens
prior to vaccination but
there were no associations between
having these pre-existing responses
and t-cell responses and some sort of
favorable outcome
next because 16 patients were hlhd
positive
they were able to use eczema to measure
the pistol frequencies
and identify peptide specific cd8 pistol
responses
so on the left hand side here you can
see changes in the cd8 frequencies at
multiple time points
starting from baseline continuing post
and these are further broken down here
in the middle diagrams
by patient response and the take-home
message here is that we did not see
any consistent trend in patient-cda
t-cell tumor antigen reactivity
among these groups after vaccination
and as with the trend observing the ali
spot data
the majority of 16 patients here had
dextromer positive
cells at baseline but again this did not
set a stage for a better clinical
outcomes for the patients
so collectively so we saw that the
responses to individual antigens
did not seem significantly impact
clinical outcome
but what we did we actually took all the
individual responses
and uh to all three shared antigens and
group them into a one combined response
and what we were able to see here based
on these kepler kepler-meyer plots
is that a vaccine in the ucda t-cell
response
showed significant association with
overall progression-free survival
with overall survival and
progression-free survival uh so going on
the uh then we're interested a little
bit more
into a effect of a previous checkpoint
blockade
uh blockade for these patients so
because um
many of these patients were in late
stage disease
they they often had previous uh
therapies
and uh here we subdivided the patients
based on uh
receiving either antiped1 or and or
ctlx4
and what we saw here was that uh tcl
responses overall
were higher in patients that had
previously received
one of the checkpoint blockades
therapies and here i'm first showing
dextromer frequencies
that show a small but significant
difference based on the
previous therapy for uh may j6
specifically
and going on uh here i'm showing a
uh frequency external frequency
responses
and uh what we see here is that
the only ma-specific diesel response
that showed
some sort of clear increase over time
was again h6
so um that that was quite an interesting
result and
it suggests that the previous blockade
of ctla4 or pd1 can slightly amplify
some of the ma-specific responses and
difference
this difference can persist through the
course of vaccination
uh all right going on next we were
also interested in profiling
the exhaustion molecules of these cells
and here i'm going to only share a pd-1
expression levels and uh what it was
interesting was to see that the best
responders the two patients that were pr
patients actually showed really really
uh extremely low levels of pd-1
on their ma-specific cd8 collections
uh the other uh exhaustion monitors did
not relate significantly with
any kind of clinical response so next we
use nanostring profiling to look at the
levels
and and really to deeply profile these
uh circulating lymphocytes
from these patients and here uh some
data for the protein counting data
for these checkpoint molecules uh pd1
and cp4
now uh what we saw is that in general
uh both of these molecules were elevated
their expression levels were elevated in
the bad outcome patients
at both measurements at both at the
baseline at
a43 so
we also analyzed this data by looking at
time dependent change and even though
this data didn't come statistically
significant
there were certainly at least for the
ctla-4 data we saw a
very close significance
in showing that the ctla4 or pd1
expression levels were higher in the bad
outcome patients
we've also used univariate cox
regression analysis
to kind of determine whether or not
their levels
at baseline or post-vaccine correlated
with
overall or progression-free survival and
indeed
uh many of these it
so we've used a pan-cancer immune
profiling panel
and cardi characterization panel in
order to better understand the pathways
and the gene expression profiles of
these
uh basically patient circulating
lymphocytes
and the way we've done this comparison
is it was based on outcome groups so we
separated the good and bad outcome
groups at both
baseline and post-vaccine treatments and
we saw certainly an interesting
signatures
or or different gene expression changes
and then we've looked at the pathway
analysis
what we saw was the following and again
just to position you
we have uh the red and blue denoted
pathways that are either upregulated or
down regulated
uh based on a clinical outcome
and broken down at baseline or day 43.
so what we saw is that a lot of
interesting pathways associated with
emptor signaling tcl receptor signaling
b-cell receptor signaling
where upper upper regulated in the in
the good outcome category
while strong uh type one interferon
response signatures
were associated with the with the worst
clinical prognosis
here is also shown that uh ctla-4
pathway
actually came up as a upregulated in the
bad outcome patients
now we've also correlated pathways with
overall and progression-free survival
and what was interesting was that we saw
the t-cell responses
were strongly correlative with overall
survival
and diesel responses with
progression-free survival
and we also saw that the interferon type
one signatures were
present in in in the low uh unfavorable
survival category now
lastly i'm going to share some data from
the two tumor biopsies
that are we are actually currently
investigating right now
where we actually applied several
nanostring uh sequencing panels to
and uh what we actually saw is uh and i
understand this is a little bit of a
complicated slide
and i just want you to focus your
attention on these different signatures
and what we actually saw is some
interesting uh hypoxia-like and
geogenesis
uh and vegeta associated signatures uh
that that actually were correlative of
bad clinical outcome
there are additional uh pathways like
integrin ecm
stromalite components stolage receptor
signaling pgf beta
again uh some consistent themes along
the
uh tumor micro environment now uh what
is interesting
is that the vegf interested us because
of some additional data that we have
collected including
blood serum cytokines and whatnot and
they've actually looked at a pathway
specifically related to these
in both three panels and what we saw
and it was really nice to see that there
were several genes that were
consistently
upregulated in the bad outcome patients
across the different panels so it was
sort of a external validation of the
data
so this is just kind of an example of
the pathways signatures that we see in
the bad outcome patients in the tumors
so collectively i would like to conclude
the talk
by by summarizing the data where we show
that a majority of our 35 patients were
successfully vaccinated
in this clinical trial and uh not
individual antigens but the combined
total
of tumor antigen-specific cd8 responses
were associated with
favorable overall progression in overall
survival
so that's that that argues for the
importance of diesel responses
in these spider vaccines and the
previous checkpoint therapy
enhanced some of the uh tumor-associated
uh antigen uh testosterone-specific
responses
uh and in some cases they uh continued
uh elevated over time
uh and the two patients with the best
clinical outcomes
certainly showed a very low pd-1
expression surface markers
uh analysis of pd-1 and ctla-4 protein
expression
uh using a protein counting nanostring
panel
uh in lymphocytes showed
increase in expression of these
checkpoint molecules
in the bad outcome patients and
what we saw is that a lot of high immune
checkpoint
type one is their fear and responses
t-cell exhaustion like gene expression
networks
were associated with uh with inferior
clinical outcome in patients
and lastly we're looking into the tumors
and so some interesting
uh like uh extracellular or
matrix stroma-like uh signatures that
associate it with inferior clinical
outcome in patients
so with that i'd like to thank uh my
mentor uh dr butterfield
and uh some of the people that
collectively helped with the work
uh of patty santos uh dina and paul
um our collaborators team halves
also from the parker institute he's in
the bioinformatics department he was
instrumental in helping with some of the
bioinformatic analyses
and also sarah warren from nanostring
from helping conducting
this nanostring sequencing research and
uh
this is a picture showing the parker
institute for cancer immunotherapy
that is where we are located and i'll be
happy to take
any questions
have you looked the whether blockade of
pd1 during
antigen presentation by dendritic cells
had any functional impact on the tumor
androgen specific t cells
so yes had uh actually engineered a
dendritic cells that were expressing
uh antipd-1 antibody and they were
co-curvatured together with with the
patient t cells and we did not see any
effect
of blockade of pd1 during the
the tumor antigen cross presentation so
uh we did not see benefit adding that uh
during the
post during the antigen presentation
however
we certainly suggest that there may be
additional mechanisms
or perhaps the blockade of the
checkpoints after the vaccination may
potentially increase the benefit of the
vaccine
did you measure the antigen expression
levels in dendritic cells
and if so did you see any correlations
between antigen expression levels
and t cell or clinical responses
so yes so we've looked at the levels of
antigen expression levels both in the
vaccines
i mean in the vaccines both by rna and
protein
and uh we did not see any correlations
between the amount of expression of
particular antigen
in the dendritic cells and better t cell
responses
so that was not apparent
did you observe any correlations between
cd4 and cd8 cell responses
so we looked at uh and actually a
reviewer asked us that
uh for our manuscript whether or not
there were any correlation between cd4
responses
so we have uh extensively analyzed cd4t
cells just like the cd80 cells
but we did not see a specific
correlation
in any way with the cd8 cells um to any
of the tumor antigens
so uh well we believe they're important
and you know many studies are coming out
of their impair importance in
immunotherapy treatments
we did not see a correlation between cd8
and cd4 t cell responses
to these shared tumor antigens
did you analyze insoluble serum
checkpoint molecules
so yes we have analyzed uh actually a
whole panel
of soluble checkpoint molecules uh
including
pd1 and ctla4 but many of those actually
did not come up
in terms of a good signal but uh what we
saw was a soluble expression of pdl2
uh as well as lag three and team three
showed some interesting correlations
with clinical outcome
and i'm going to point out soluble pdl2
that
showed a significant association
done by uh hazard ratio analysis as well
as uh
correlative analyses that the elevated
levels of pdl2 actually uh predicted a
better
outcome in patients now while we don't
know what it really
means there are some studies indicating
that pdl2 may have some
different and perhaps even activation
specific roles but
we don't understand what it means yet
but the clinical correlations were very
significant for pdl2
so i'd like to summarize the study uh by
saying that
uh while most of the patients were
significantly
um vaccinated uh in our clinical trial
uh individual tumor antigens were not
predictive of clinical response
the combined total was certainly
impactful
in terms of clinical outcome
such as overall survival and
progression-free survival responses
nanostring signature uh profiling uh
certainly demonstrated in
interesting uh patterns in in a
checkpoint molecule expression such as
pd1 ctla4
and we show a strong associations with
or their increase
uh strong associations with inferior
survival and patients
um i would like to thank everybody for
the attention
uh i'd like to thank again the
organizers for putting this event
together
uh and nanostring for uh sponsoring the
event and
thank you